pleased to have right here on the rich
eisen show
courtesy of our friends at fedex to talk
about the fedex air and ground player of
the year awards to be handed out
on thursday night at nfl honors as a guy
who had one of the best seasons in the
history of running and running backs in
the nfl he is indianapolis colt
jonathan taylor good to see you sir good
to see you as well rich thank you so
much for having me here oh it's a
pleasure to see you and have you here
you know i'm a big fan of yours i've
told that to you over the phone no i got
to tell it to your face
even though uh here's what i'm going to
do on this program as you can see i've
got the rich eisenstein mug right here
i'm going to replace this mug with the
mug that i unfortunately also own
because of jonathan taylor oh absolutely
and it is the mug that uh jj watt gave
me
because this cup holds rich eisens tears
final score wisconsin 35 michigan 14.
and how many of these 35 points did you
i i think uh account for on this day
john i had like two or three touchdowns
that day yeah you've even lost track of
the number of points that you put on
this mug
so
thank you for this mug even though i
don't really mean it um sorry about that
he's so sorry you're too nice you're too
kind but this mug is in my uh on my desk
two touchdowns along a 72 203 yards that
day for jonathan taylor and you didn't
even finish that day right did you did
you play that whole game that day or no
i think we i think we got pulled i think
we got pulled
it was 28 nothing at halftime okay i
don't want to keep rubbing the salt but
you know what i'm just saying yeah you
could stop dispensing information
and so yeah you made some saturdays very
long sorry but i think it's okay you're
very fun though you know
you're not really sorry are you
sorry not sorry okay very good very very
good uh all right uh man
uh where do you think this season came
from for you jonathan i really think it
just came from my rookie season just
coming in the year that i came into
learning everything virtually
finally get going halfway through the
year um and then us falling short you
know in buffalo and using that using
that fuel throughout the offseason to be
able to dive into the playbook even more
to be able to learn how to play the game
at a high level and then of course
upping my game you know physically and
and then being able to put that
on in production on the field um
starting with camp you know starting
fast
and so because we're talking about um
you know your
draft mate in joe burrow quite a bit
this week as you might you might imagine
and talking about how he sees the game i
mean we had kurt warner on
previous to you and he was talking about
how his superpower is what's between his
temples in a way for decision making
what about you
you just said about learning the game
and getting to know what to do how did
you
get from your rookie season to this
season based on that so really it was
the help from the veterans in the locker
room like i mentioned our rookie year
was cover year we all learned we didn't
have any
otas anything of that nature you know
the rookies just came in during camp
guns blazing so having the veterans
being able to help me out
and have me focus and learn on what to
do
my rookie season and then adding on top
of that going into my second year
now i don't have to worry as much as
about that it's really how do i do these
little things at a high level you know
those little bits and pieces of
knowledge that the veterans give me to
be able to incorporate that when you
don't have to think about okay what did
i just learn over the course of these
past few months it's okay this is the
play call okay now let me see what the
defense is giving me and how can i take
my game to the next level what can i
manipulate based on what the defense is
showing me interesting
which one do you have a moment or a run
this year you had so many of them in
where this is something you're prideful
to mention that i saw or i could see and
i did you got something so it really
happened during the preseason this year
so
unfortunately i wasn't in
this this game but
we had a run call
and i made a predetermining decision
from the sideline but that's exactly
where the running back took the ball and
placed the ball that play so um don't
know if that's what he was thinking as
well but just from
my experience in my mind i'm thinking
okay if i was him i'm thinking the ball
might hit here and that's exactly where
he took the ball so during that
preseason moment is where i thought okay
so all of that study and all that work
all of those bits and pieces of
knowledge from those veterans that i
soaked up like a sponge is actually
starting to pay off i'm starting to see
it now so you jonathan taylor giving me
an example of a play that you didn't run
but you ran in your head
watching while not in the game
that didn't count in the standings is
that basically what your answer was to
yes it is yes it is and and that's where
you want to be you know speaking of
veterans you want to be able to just see
the game and be in it and be able to
dissect it be able to understand what's
going on when you're able to to do that
when you're in the game i mean it's a
whole different picture it's just
everything is just a slowed down version
well if you'll just excuse me for a
moment uh chris brockman he's our
general manager of our fantasy team is
there any way that we can guarantee we
get jonathan taylor next year as well
can we can we do that is there any way
of hearing all of these answers that we
can get on that i'll make some calls
thank you i'm sorry jonathan i didn't
interrupt our conversation
how many fantasy league owners did uh
four team uh owners come up to you and
say thank you for oh my god so many i
mean i never realized until i got into
the nfl you knew fantasy football was a
big deal you played fantasy you never
did you play it i've never played it
okay but you knew you know people played
fantasy it's a fun thing to do but until
you get into the nfl and realize
how serious it can get like the fan they
the fantasy teams are
what they are living for during the
football season they're like i need to
win every single week
similar to how we're in our minds we
need to win every single week but you
know it's fantasy and they're really
adamant about it right and then they
like people i imagine want to hug you
and want to oh they just like they love
you like i'm like you won my daddy's
fantasy league or you you want me three
thousand dollars i'm like whoa whoa
i'm thank you i'm happy for you what's
10 or something like that you know oh
man that is
that is amazing uh so it's you nick
chubb and joe mixon for fedex ground
player of the year
um and mixon's in the super bowl huh
do you know these guys at all i do i do
i i know nick chubb very well um and joe
mix and i've gotten to to me and know
over the course of these past two years
you just look at the way those guys run
it's insane i mean
nick chubb just a natural pure runner
being able to just take it the distance
a strong runner as well and then joe
mixon i mean you guys are seeing it on
display this year i mean he's he's able
to do everything he's able to run strong
he's able to break tackles he's able to
have those subtle decisive cuts i mean
i mean those are two
i hate to say it but you know going up
against those two i'm like man why does
it have to be those two no i know well
obviously you've got a heck of a a
a resume for that brady justin herbert
matthew stafford for the fedex air and
player
uh
of the year those are your nominees
their voting ends tonight so you can
cast your ballot for the awards at
nfl.com fedex and through the nfl's
handle on twitter or on the nfl mobile
app
and the neat thing is uh fedex is going
to donate 20 grand right 20 grand to an
hbcu that is awesome i'm just being able
to to have an opportunity to be a part
of that is something that that i'm truly
thankful and honored um to to be a part
of because you know it's just something
that everybody you know deserves an
opportunity no matter
where you go to school at so being able
to have that opportunity to be a part of
that is something that you know i really
feel good about okay um jonathan taylor
here on the rich eisen show so uh you're
from new jersey
okay where in new jersey are you from so
i'm from south jersey exit one salem new
jersey exit one very good one uh mike
deltufa what exit are you for yeah it's
a tournament that's a turnpike exit you
just gave right so what about the the
garden state parkway what's uh what exit
would you be on that one i don't take
the parkway very good so that's that's
that's way east okay so but one night
south jersey that's practically delaware
we're like i'm like 15 minutes from
delaware okay very 15 minutes
all right so what's your egg where were
you turnpike yeah what 13w okay i
believe 13. i'm from staten island
that's 13 as well so you go the other
way yeah right yes i go into the new
york side of things so what's your town
again what's your hometown livingston my
so she's down near you now you hear how
he sounds how come you don't sound like
that's that's south jersey so
a lot of people from like it's
philadelphia that's about philly area so
i'm like 25 minutes maybe 30 minutes
from philadelphia so you have no accent
at all not even a philly accent
it's kind of weird we're in that weird
space because we're not philadelphia
we're still jersey right but we're not
north jersey correct where you sound
like cam yeah okay so
um and then you're not at delaware i
mean they're we're not delaware we're
not delaware
hackles up there so how did you get to
wisconsin it's because there's that
rondaine pipeline
something like that but also
corey clement okay he's from glasgow
that's right so he's i'm like right down
the street from him we're like also 25
30 minutes from glassboro okay so me
being in eighth grade
seeing him terrorize south jersey then
having success at the university of
wisconsin and then ultimately me getting
that opportunity at offer right doing my
own research finding out it was a top 20
academic institution because i always
loved learning so i always wanted to
push myself off of the field right but
then i also was able to push myself on
the field against top players in the
country so that was kind of a deal
breaker so where else could you have
gone what are what were your other
options so i had the opportunity to go
to rutgers boston college i had the
opportunity to go ivy league as well
which was was really tough
um just because you know you go to an
ivy league school you
your chances out of school are very high
to be successful um and like i said i
was always
in tune i loved learning so being able
to push myself off the field that was
almost a no-brainer but i felt like the
university of wisconsin gave me both
options once i you know sat down for
those two three days and did a ton of
research and solved the top 20 academic
institution i thought that's what i need
right there i'm trying to retroactively
get you out of the big ten
so um
which ivy league schools were knocking
on your door so i had the opportunity
to go to harvard and i had the
opportunity to go to yale how about them
apples
so um
and um you could have gotten you i i
can't imagine you in the ivy league
would have been just it was a tough
decision no no no i know
but i'm talking football yeah
you i mean you and the ivy league would
have been
just like a cheat code i would think
because you were in the big ten so i can
only imagine that would be the case in
the ivy league you know i'm just i try
not to think about myself in ivy league
too much because then i'm like man i
definitely had a chance to go live
league and then i'm like
man the university of wisconsin gave me
a great education and a great experience
on the field i'm like yeah i made the
best decision sure that's also a nice
campus to be a big man on um as well oh
the campus is in wisconsin oh my gosh
yeah beautiful at the terrace on the
lake um what's your what did you get
your degree in philosophy
huh yeah okay philosophy what do you
philosophize about you again so i really
loved ethics and applied ethics because
really those are things that you can
really
have day-to-day real-life examples and
really critically think about
okay very good
i'm philosophizing again about you no
not being in the big ten at all but
unfortunately that happened rich the ivy
league rushing record is four thousand
seven hundred and fifteen yards and
who's that person jonathan a guy named
ed mariano oh no dude he was on hill
street blues he was an actor oh yes a
guy named
there you go
jonathan rushed for
six thousand one hundred and seventy
four yards yeah it would have been yeah
it was michigan blues you know i mean
that was unfortunately my favorite
touchable record i know very kind yes
uh so jonathan um in between us has been
our friend vince this entire time i
don't know if you've noticed this trophy
sitting to your left oh you can't miss
it okay you can't miss it what would it
mean for you to pick this thing up and
win it one day for you i mean that would
that would be everything that's why you
play the game you play the game the
hoisted above your head
kiss it like it's one of your own i mean
that's that's why you play the game and
that's why you you have those long days
in the off season those early mornings
yeah that's why
you do what you do that's why you pay
attention to plays that you're not in in
the preseason that's why you do it
mental reps that's why middle reps add
up to hoisting that right i know it's
it's um it's a piece of tiffany uh
hardware that uh you can't like walk
into the store and go get you know
that's earned it is that and by that
well i look forward to you one day
doing that because you're all right
you agree with that and good luck on
this award and every other that you are
up for what an incredible second year
and i look forward to more from you and
you're welcome here anytime oh jonathan
rich thank you so much it was it's been
a pleasure thank you for saying that i
appreciate that man and uh now i'm going
to take this mug and put it away
oh my gosh jj watt was so smug about it
i guess he put the he put the smug and
mug i mean he was just like it's coming
you're gonna get it and
and um
be prepared yes and interestingly enough
it's funny that you know for a
right-hander it puts the it puts the the
score right there on the camera and
normally jj's being accused it's all
about him so
for lefties it's about him and for
righties which i am there's the mug
right there
thank you jonathan taylor you be well
you go forth and you keep doing it so
thanks for coming on thank you so much
rich you got it jonathan taylor right
here on the rich eisen show hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here